[Musique]
nous avons dix sept mille établissements
donc qui en demandait le chômage partiel
qui représente à peu près de 112 1722
salariés c'est à peu près 50 % des
établissements de du des yvelines
donc c'est quand même à un point
important avec bien sûr restauration
hôtellerie qui sont les plus marquées et
après bien sûr la l'industrie la
métallerie la construction
c'est une plateforme qui s'appelle cci
entraide qui permet justement des
échanges de solidarité et de
complémentarité entre entreprises dont
les entreprises peuvent faire des offres
où certains recherchent des produits
donc ça permet justement d'avoir des
échanges solidaires entre entreprises
dans cette situation difficile mais ça
peut je pense perdurer par la suite et
je l'espère il ya aussi donc une autre
façon qu'on a mis en place ce qui
s'appelle mais commerce à domicile qui
permet justement de référence et les
commerces qui ont mis en place des
livraisons à domicile et donc cette
ville dans les yvelines
donc on choisit ce système c'est poissy
mantes la jolie les mureaux maurepas
houdan camplong sainte honorine andré
vie voilà donc c'est une plateforme qui
permet justement d'aider les commerces
de centre-ville dans leur livraison à
domicile
we7 cette relance elle va être
progressive à être progressif tout
simplement parce qu'il ya quelques gérer
filière qui vont démarrer comme le
bâtiment et les travaux publics qui vont
démarrer assez vite avant la fin du mois
d'avril
mais bon les difficultés qui vient voir
bien sûr ces deux d'avoir tous les
éléments sanitaires nécessaires pour
justement permettre à ces entreprises de
travailler c'est-à-dire des masques des
blues tout ce qui est nécessaire
et puis une nouvelle organisation du
travail aussi pour les entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics ce qui
va justement créé un surcoût pour ces
entreprises et ce surcoût va se
retrouver bien sûr dans leurs devis et
dans leurs propositions
c'est évident donc c'est un surcoût qui
va être nécessaire et à plus long terme
il faut penser à une relocalisation un
autre modèle de fonctionnement de
l'industrie de l'économie sur nos
territoires
il faut profiter justement de ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire de la livraison à domicile des
circuits courts d'une utilisation un peu
plus importante de tout ce qui est de
tout le numérique donc et ça il faut il
faut que ça dure je pense qu'il faut que
ça continue